[Musique]
je t'écoute de pédaleurs j'aime bien
petit grain de bois toi j'ai envie de
créer pour toi la séquence est prise
deux on doit jouer vite là les babys aux
oiseaux sauvages oncle et honda c'est
qu'il a un petit grain de voix celui ci
un des coups de pied de la jetée dans la
salle de bal d'un décret pour toi
[Musique]
en plus du titre à new milton allait
sauver shopping en aller bébé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est là
[Musique]
et on a été balisé choisis tes plus
belles robes
tu sors
merci à denis wathier brebis valérie
marquis animal meurt on va appeler yann
moix
on va essayer de le piéger tu veux dire
que tu es en galère parce que tu t'es
fait choper par ton voisin parce que tu
a défoncé sa voiture avec son scooter ou
bien encore tu t'es fait choper avec son
scooter
je vais partir bientôt tuer ou à la bad
dans toi je suis je ne vais rien lâcher
ma grand mère un nombre demain tu
rentres de bannu vers ho [ __ ]
ben ça va me suis avec eux cyril vers le
bas l'inspecteur blanc
il ya celle où battu la voilà est-ce que
tu peux dire est ce qu'on doit être
blague c'est pas mal
[Musique]